THE POWER
OF THE COMMITTEE SO FAR HAS BEEN
THAT THE MOST DAMNING TESTIMONY
HAS BEEN FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE
FOR DONALD TRUMP, THAT WORKED IN
THE WEST WING.
THESE ARE NOT DEEP STATERS OR
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS.
TONIGHT WE'LL HEAR FROM DONALD
TRUMP HIMSELF.
BUT THE MOST DAMNING PART, ADAM
KINZINGER TWEETING OUT THIS
MORNING, PEOPLE WHO WORKED IN
THE WEST WING, THE CAPITOL,
REMEMBER THAT DAY, THE CAPITOL
WAS UNDER ATTACK.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
BEING BEATEN, WINDOWS BROKEN,
THE BUILDING STORMED AND
RANSACKED, CHANTS OF "HANG MIKE
PE
PENCE," CHANTS OF "LET'S FIND
NANCY PELOSI," THIS IS WHAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING --
>> WAS THE PRESIDENT IN THAT
PRIVATE DINING ROOM THE WHOLE
TIME THAT THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL WAS GOING ON, WHO DID HE
GO TO -- AGAIN, TO YOUR
KNOWLEDGE -- TO THE OVAL OFFICE,
THE WHITE HOUSE SITUATION ROOM,
ANYWHERE ELSE?
>> TO THE BEST OF MY
RECOLLECTION, HE WAS ALWAYS IN
THE DINING ROOM.
>> WHAT DID THAT SAY?
MR. MEADOWS OR THE PRESIDENT?
AT ALL DURING THAT BRIEF
ENCOUNTER THAT YOU WERE IN THE
DINING ROOM.
WHAT DO YOU RECALL?
>> I THINK EVERYBODY WAS
WATCHING THE TV.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHETHER HE WAS
WATCHING TV IN THE DINING ROOM
WHEN YOU TALKED TO HIM ON
JANUARY 6th?
>> IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT HE
WAS WATCHING TELEVISION.
>> WHEN YOU WERE IN THE DINING
ROOM, IN THESE DISCUSSIONS, WAS
THE VIOLENCE HAPPENING,
PHYSICALLY, ON THE SCREEN, ON
THE TELEVISION?
>> YES.
>> THAT, MELANIE, IS WHAT MAKES
IT SO DAMNING, THAT'S THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL THERE, RETIRED
COUNSEL, KELLOGG THERE, KAYLEIGH
McENANY.
THE PRESIDENT WAS WATCHING ON
TELEVISION.
THE GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WAS UNDER ATTACK.
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS BEING
THREATENED.
THE PRESIDENT WAS WATCHING ON
TV.
>> WE ALREADY KNEW THAT AIDES
WERE GOING IN THERE AND TELLING
HIM, SO HE WAS HEARING IT WITH
HIS OWN EARS.
NOW WE KNOW WITHOUT ANY DOUBT
THAT HE WAS SEEING IT WITH HIS
OWN EYES.
AND NOT ONLY DID HE NOT ACT, BUT
WE'VE HEARD OTHER TESTIMONY THAT
HE WAS SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON, INCLUDING THE "HANG
MIKE PENCE" CHAPNTS.
ADAM KINZINGER SAID HE WAS
GLEEFULLY WATCHING.
AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT HIS ACTIONS LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6th AND ON JANUARY 6th
AND WE'RE STARTING TO GET A
PICTURE AFTERWARDS, INCLUDING
JANUARY 7th, DURING THOSE
OUTTAKES, WHEN THAT FILM WAS
FILMED, HE WAS NOT SORRY, HE WAS
NOT REMORSEFUL.
HE WANTED TO CONTINUE SPREADING
THESE LIES AND THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WOW HE'S ACTED
EVER SINCE.
>> WANTED TO CONTINUE TO CALL
THE PEOPLE WHO STORMED THE
CAPITOL PATRIOTS.
PATRIOTS.
NOT RIOTERS, NOT CRIMINALS.
>> RIGHT.
THIS WAS A SHOW THAT DONALD
TRUMP PRODUCED, RIGHT?
IT UNFOLDED IN THE WAY THAT HE
WANTED TO IT HAPPEN, FROM THAT
TWEET HE SENT AFTER THAT WHITE
HOUSE MEETING, SAYING, COME TO
THE CAPITOL, IT WILL BE WILD, TO
HIS PROPERTY TESTATIONS WHEN HEN
FRONT OF THAT CROWD THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO MARCH TO THE
CAPITOL.
OF COURSE HE WAS SITTING THERE
AND WATCHING IT, BECAUSE THOSE
FOLKS WERE CALLED TO THE CAPITOL
BY HIM AND DOING WHAT HE WANT
THED
THEM TO DO.
THE ONLY THING THAT WENT WRONG
IS IT ACTUALLY DIDN'T WORK.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE ZWRTO OVERTHR
THE GOVERNMENT.
MIKE PENCE DIDN'T DO WHAT DONALD
TRUMP WANTED HIM TO DO.
BUT IT IS A DAMNING PORTRAIT OF
INACTION.
NOT JUST A DERELICTION OF HIS
DUTY AS A PRESIDENT, BUT A
DERELICTION OF HIS DUTY AS
HUMAN.
SOMEONE WHO CAN STOP THIS
RAMPAGE AND VIOLENCE FROM
HAPPENING, AND THERE HE IS
SITTING AND WATCHING IT OF
TELEVISION.
>> AND YOU LIVED THROUGH THIS,
COVERING THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE,
IF SOMETHING DIDN'T GO HIS WAY,
TRUMP SAID, THAT PERSON IS A
LIAR, THEY'RE WITH THE FAKE
NEWS, THEY'RE A REPUBLICAN IN
NAME ONLY, THEY'RE A LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT, THEY'RE THE DEEP
STATE.
WE CAN SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
PEOPLE.
THESE ARE TRUMP INSIDERS, SARAH
MATTHEWS, CASSIDY HUTCHINSON,
PAT CIPOLLONE, THE LIST GOES ON
AND ON.
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE WHO WORKED
WITH DONALD TRUMP, WORKED IN THE
CAMPAIGN, WORKED WITH HIM TO THE
END, SOME FROM THE BEGINNING.
IT'S JUST IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY CAN CRITICIZE HOW THE
COMMITTEE WAS FORMED.
THEY CAN CRITICIZE THE DEMOCRATS
ON THE COMMITTEE.
THAT TESTIMONY IS DAMNING
BECAUSE IT COMES FROM PEOPLE WHO
WERE VERY LOYAL TO DONALD TRUMP
UNTIL THE END.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I COVERED THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
FOR FOUR YEARS.
I COVERED THE NSC FOR QUITE A
BIT.
MATTHEW POTT ITINGPOTTINGER, SA
MATHEWS, WHILE THEY MIGHT NOT BE
THE MOST HOUSEHOLD NAMES,
THEY'RE VERY RESPECTED,
INCLUDING MATTHEW POTTINGER,
VERY INVOLVED WITH SOME OF THE
TOP FOREIGN POLICY.
HIS TESTIMONY CANNOT JUST BE
TOSSED OUT.
HE CANNOT BE PAINTED AS SOMEONE
WHO IS JUST A LOW-LEVEL STAFFER.
AND HE, I THINK AS WELL AS SARAH
MARSHALL, ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE TIMELINE OF JANUARY
6th, AND NOT ONLY SHOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS JUST
WATCHING TV, BUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT POINTS THAT HE COULD
HAVE DONE THE RIGHT THING S.
>> AND ALL THE PEOPLE COMING AND
BEGGING HIM TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.